c'est une première les restos du coeur
organisent leurs premières portes
ouvertes samedi 25 juin dans toute la
france et les yvelines participent que
ce soit pour récolter des informations
sur l'aide alimentaire ou bien pour
s'engager au sein de l'association les
bénévoles seront là pour répondre à
toutes les questions
c'est vraiment une première problème
pour les restos du coeur jeudi d'une
façon générale donc dans toute la france
pourquoi pourquoi la journée portes
ouvertes c'est que jusqu'à ce jour les
réseaux sont surtout connus
en termes de communication extérieure
surtout par le concert des et
la collecte nationale donc ces deux
temps forts qui ont qui avait lieu en
début d'année et là l'idée de
l'association nationale c'est de
relancer un peu l'image des restos alors
que la précarité s'aggrave et que les
prix augmentent ces journées portes
ouvertes sont l'occasion pour les restos
du coeur d'aller à la rencontre de ceux
qui n'osent pas pousser les portes des
centres d'accueil au total une quinzaine
de sites seront ouverts le matin ou
l'après midi dont le chantier
d'insertion aux clayes-sous-bois le
premier travail c'est la socialisation
socialisation et que lorsqu'on a levé
tous ces obstacles tous ces blocages on
peut ensuite aller vers la recherche
d'emploi donc il ya des bénévoles pour
chaque bénéficiaire il ya un bénévole
qui l'accompagnent dans sa recherche
d'emploi dans l'élaboration de son
projet professionnel souvent méconnus du
public l'association ne se charge pas
seulement de faire de l'aide alimentaire
elle s'engage également dans
l'accompagnement au numérique juridique
ou même dans l'aide au logement cette
journée est ouverte à tous et se
poursuivra par le bal des restos animées
par des dj